temple
Guandi à la fin du 19e siècle les
Chinois installés dans l'île se
retrouvent dans des écoles des salles de
réunion et des temples ces lieux de
culte sont dédiés à Guandi qui incarne
notamment la fidélité l'esprit
chevaleresque le courage et la maîtrise
de soi il est aussi considéré par les
commerçants comme le dieu de la
richesse les trois temples de
Saint-Denis se trouvent dans le quartier
du Petit Marché lieu de commerce et
d'échange peu visible de la rue le
temple des chanes ou temple de la
prospérité éternelle est installé en
1896 dans une ancienne maison
reconstruite en dur dans les années
1950 couleur liturgique de la fête du
bonheur et de la divinité le rouge est
ici
omniprésent l'hôtel de Gandy est précédé
d'une table décoré de vases rituels et
de
portebougie en 1905 la communauté
chinoise du sud de lillele installe son
lieu de culte dans une maison créole de
la rue Marius har Leblond en plein
quartier résidentiel de
Saint-Pierre au milieu du 20e siècle ce
premier bâtiment en bois est remplacé
par un édifice en pierre qui ne possède
aucune caractéristique de l'architecture
religieuse
chinoise seul les calligraphies du
fronton et le portail réalisé dans les
années 1980 évoque cette tradition
architecturale
inspiré des temples de la dynastie Song
le futur temple Guandi de Terre Sainte
dessiné par l'architecte réunionné James
ONG marque quant à lui un réel retour
aux
sources